تحدثنا عن الجهود التي تبذلها الفرق
السعوديه التي تتابعها وما تم حتى الان
نعم بالفعل احمد نتواجد في هذا الموقع في
الابراهيم لتحديدا في غازي عنتاب حيث
عشرات
المباني المخدمه التي استلمها الفريق
الانقاذ السعودي منذ يومين ويتم العمل على
مدار الساعه على مدار 24 ساعه في هذا
الموقع وفي مواقع مختلفه في عمليات
الانقاذ وعمليات ايضا انتشال الجثث حتى
هذه اللحظه والامال لا زالت قصيصه جدا مع
وجود او مع مرور سبعه ايام حتى الان تحدث
عن اكثر من 150 ساعه رائحه الجثث احمد
بدات تنتشر بشكل كبير جدا في هذا الموقع
الكثير من الجثث تم انتشالها قبل ساعات
حيث تم انتشار ما يقارب سبعه جثث وايضا في
اللحظات القليله الماضيه كان هنالك ايضا
جثه تم انتشالها في هذا الموقع حيث اب
يحمل ابنه الصغير وهو محتضنه في هذا
الموقع تم انتشار هذه الجثه في في هذا
الوضع حقيقه الوضع ماساوي في هذه في هذا
الموقع تحديدا حيث نتحدث عن عشرات الاسر
المتواجده في هذا الموقع
ينتظرون اي بصيص امل لاي خبر عن ذويهم في
هذا الموقع وهم يتسمرون في هذا الموقع منذ
ايام في لحظات ترقب وتامل
وامل ولو كان بسيطا مع مرور سبعه ايام
واعتضاء الفرص بشكل كبير جدا
لانتشال ايه او ايجاد ايه مفقودين ولكن
الاخبار الاتيه من سواء كان غازي عنتاب
هنالك بعض القصص عن اشخاص تم انتشالهم
سواء كان الاطفال او
الرجال او حتى النساء يعني تعطيهم بعض
الامل بالاضافه الى ذلك اليوم في غازي
عنتاب تم رصد هزه ارضيه بقياس ثلاثه
في غازي عنتاب بالاضافه اليوم امس كان
هنالك ايضا هزه ارضيه
شعرنا فيها في الحقيقه في هذه في غازي
عنتاب اهتزت المباني قليلا لم يكن هناك
اهتزاز كبير ولكن كانوا هنالك اهتزاز وهذا
ما يصعب عمليه
عمليات البحث والانقاذ في هذه المواقع
التي يتواجد فيها اجهزه نشاهد ان فريق
البحث والانقاذ السعودي جلب بعض الاجهزه
للاستشعار تحديدا الجهاز
المرتفع في هذا الموقع يرصد عمليه
المباني المحيطه في هذا الموقع وتحديدا
التي تم اخلائها والقائمه حيث ايه ميلان
ايه
حركه لهذا المبنى يتم اخلاء هذا الموقع
بشكل كامل نظرا
لخطورته خطورته حتى على فرق الانقاذ
المتواجده
لاستشعار ايه
اضرار قد تنجم او ايه هزات قد تسبب انهيار
ايه مباني وهي خاليه في الحقيقه
العمل لازال مستمر فريق الانقاذ السعودي
قال بان العمل سيستمر لمده على الاقل
ساعتين في هذا الموقع من ثم سينتقل لمواقع
اخرى في منطقه غازي عنتاب جدا عبد المحسن
يعني بالتاكيد ان الفرق السعوديه تعمل في
ظروف استثنائيه وصعبه جدا بطبيعه الحال
لكن ما هي ابرز التحديات والصعوبات التي
تواجه هذه الفرق السعوديه بحسب مشاهدات
ايضا ومتابعتك
تحديات كبيره جدا نتحدث عن هذه الانقاض
التي قد تنهدم على ايه شخص من هذا الفريق
وايضا على المباني المجاوره التي قد تنهدم
بايه لحظه كل هذه التحديات اي بالاضافه
الى
صعوبه الوصول الى بعض الاشخاص في الداخل
سبعه ايام من البحث المتواصل لفرق متواصله
فريق الدفاع المدني السعودي استلم هذا
الموقع منذ يومين الفرق الاخرى التي كانت
تعمل في هذا الموقع انتقلت الى مواقع اخرى
ايضا الحاجه الكبيره واحده من ابرز
الصعوبات شاهدت الكثير من المباني التي
انهدمت جراء الزلزال يوم الامس لم يتم
العمل عليها ابدا ايضا تصلني رسائل من بعض
الاشخاص المتواجدين في المناطق مختلفه
لمباني مهدمه منذ ايام يقولون ان ذويهم في
داخل هذا المبنى ولكن لم يتم العمل عليه
الاف المباني نتحدث عن اكثر من 5000 مبنى
منهدم فبالتالي
فرق الانقاذ لم تستطيع حتى الدوليه منها
التي وصلت لم تستطيع ان تستكمل كافه او
تعمل على كافه المواقع فبالتالي العمل على
بعض المواقع لا زال لم يصلها لم تصلها حتى
الانتشار الجثث الكثير من الاهالي
المتواجدين في بعض المواقع فقدوا الامل
بشكل كبير جدا ببقاء ذويهم احياء فبالتالي
هم يريدون فقط الجثه يريدون استكمال عمليه
دفنهم في هذا في عدد مواقع ايضا بعض
المشاهدات التي شاهدتها ونحن نتجول في بعض
المدن التركيه الجنوبيه شاهدت في الحقيقه
عشرات السيارات من الاسعافات في الطريق ما
بين هاتاي وبين غازي عنتاب تحدث عن مقابر
جماعيه لالاف الذين قضوا جراء هذا الزلزال
ماساه الحقيقه كبيره جدا ايضا بعض الطرق
اغلقت
ويتم فتحها بجراءه او بطريق يدوي اي ان
سائق السياره ينزل ويزيل بعض الانقاض التي
نزلت على المبنى او حتى الاسلاك التي نزلت
بالاضافه لذلك شاهدت ايضا وهذا شيء بعض من
بعض الخطوط التي وجها لها لبعض الاهالي لا
زال ماكث في بيته المهدم وتحديدا في بعض
القرى التي لن تصلها
الفرق الانقاذ شاهدت عشرات الاشخاص
المتواجدين في مبنى في مساء يوم الامس في
مبنى منعدم وماكدينه في الغرفه السفليه
للمبنى في تالي خطوره كبيره جدا عليهم فرق
الانقاذ لم تستطع حتى الان ان
تعمل على كافه المواقع في التالي يتم
الانتقال من موقع الى اخر بحسب المجريات
في هذا الموقع وفي المواقع المختلفه في
غازي عنتاب او في صوره قاتل رسمها في هذه
المناطق عبد المح سن ربما نعود اليك في
ثاني في ثنائي هذه التغطيه هذه الساعه او
الساعه المقبله شكرا لك من غازي عنتاب
وانت معنا مفرد العربي عبد المحسن الحربي